je fais la vida belle on vient à cannes
c'est incroyable moi je continue ma vie
je reprends le travail que j'avais à
bercy en vente parce que je suis jeune
je venais d'arrêter l'école j'ai 18 ans
on propose plein de choses et je me dis
non mais impossible je ne sais pas faire
un film d'époque l'articulation j'aurais
jamais le temps je travaillerai pas non
mais donc je dis pas mal non j'essaye
beaucoup de profiter du moment pour vous
retourner travailler en fait ouais je
retourne travailler puis je suis pour
moi ça quand les conjoints à cannes pour
la vie d'adulte on me dit tu sais que ta
vie va changer tu sais que je m'étais
ils sont malades déjà je veux pas
qu'elle change donc tout ça je vois pas
pourquoi je changerais et je m'en suis
rendu compte plus tard je pense après
l'avoir beaucoup beaucoup voyagé de me
dire ok maintenant on me propose des
premiers rôles et les gens pensent que
je suis capable de le faire qu'est ce
que je fais je claque
quand tu veux que je te l'appelant
bonjour à des exemples aux bons jours je
me suis demandé à del quelle expérience
physique est ce que c'est pour vous de
jouer dans tous les films j'avoue que je
théorise pas vraiment le corps et que
j'essaye de faire ça assez naturellement
mais depuis un canton dupieux et ça
s'accentue avec la mission c'est
vraiment des réalisateurs où travaillent
ils passent à travers le corps par
exemple les à pour créer une forme de
complicité avec ma fille c'était dur
pour moi d'être pas froide mais d'être
dans quelque chose de d'habitude avec
celle qui joue ma fille et moi
naturellement je vais être plus
chaleureuse plus tactiles etc elle nous
faisait faire des exercices où je devais
être debout comme une branche mais la
petite elle devait juste ne jamais
toucher le sol et se déplacer sur moi
comment qui change mais à vous entendre
souvent c'est vraiment de l'instinct
c'est un mot qui revient très souvent
chez vous que vous parlez de votre
métier en fait sincèrement j'essaie de
trouver une méthode de travail j'ai pas
trouvé une ligne de conduite que
j'arrive à appliquer à chaque fois j'en
rêve est en fait à chaque film j'essaye
de trouver quelque chose de différent
j'avais déjà un truc super journée temps
super pas fou non plus bien que vous
préparez pas à quoi si voilà mais un
jour j'ai vu quelque chose qui m'a
rassuré avant avant de faire un choix
pour mes personnages je me disais mais
qu'est ce qu'il me dit qu'elle écoute
cette musique qu'est-ce qui me dit
qu'elle marche comme ça j'avais toujours
le doute qui mange un peu trop le
cerveau et un jour c'est marrant j'ai vu
le documentaire de jim carrey tu sais
jim and et il a dit un truc super
intéressant il racontait une fois où il
a eu je me compare absolument pas jim
carrey a lancé même si un honneur il
disait qu'une fois il a eu un rôle il
était sur la plage et s'est dit je suis
sûr que mon personnage il pense qu'il
est capable de communiquer avec les
dauphins et je me suis dit mais en fait
c'est peut-être ça la clé juste si j'y
crois ça existe c'est peut-être juste
une question de deux fois décalé il se
passe quelque chose devant une caméra
dans le premier plan de ce film les cinq
diable on voit votre personnage se
retourner et fixer la caméra qu'il ya
des visages pour sauter quoi vous qu une
caméra et posés sur vous je l'oubli
facilement tout de suite bah ouais
sincèrement je suis plus stressé quand
il s'agit d'être moi même que quand
c'est un personnage où j'arrive
complètement par exemple à travers le
corps à mon les dire et c'est ça ça
m'excite même il paraît que même quand
la caméra n'est pas posés sur vous vous
continuez à pleurer vous continuez à
donner des émotions continuer à jouer
moi ça me parle à moi je sais que j'ai
vachement besoins des acteurs de tout le
monde en fait sur un plateau je trouve
que tout le monde construit un
personnage de la régie à la musique
c'est pour ça que c'était super aussi
dans l'ead jouer avec un enfant un
enfant c'est toujours présente et de
l'instinct aux silhouettes est toujours
obligé aucune prise va se ressembler
c'est un enfant quoi donc c'est super
instinctif et je sais que moi j'ai
besoin des autres pour pour jouer pour
que mes personnages existent au point de
devenir le personnage au fait tout
simplement ouais après quand le film il
s'arrête je pas du tout enchanté par les
personnages qu'est ce que vous mettez de
vous en fait à chaque fois dans un rôle
qu'est ce que vous allez chercher là
sans s'arrêter donc il faut y croire
faut croire ça vous refuserait toujours
un personnage auquel vous croyez pas
ouais mais ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
que je la même morale que mes
personnages par contre ce serait prendre
mieux ça vous embête et après un film
comme la villa del d'abdellatif kechiche
palme d'or ici même il ya neuf ans dans
lequel kechiche est allé jusqu'à changer
le nom du personnage pour coller à votre
réalité justement à l'appeler adèle
qu'une confusion s'installe peut-être
qu'on ait cru cadel dans le film c'était
aden je m'en suis pas rendu compte en
plus on me l'a annoncée quand on a su
qu'on était sélectionné à cannes donc
j'ai appris que ça s'appelait la vida
d'elle il l'avait garder mon prénom
parce qu'il faisait tellement d'impro
est tellement de scène absolument pas
écrit tout maîtriser que les gens
m'appeler par mon prénom il m'a dit tu
vois ça dérange pas qu'on le garde j'ai
dit non pas du tout il m'a dit en plus
la victoire justice en arabe et je crois
que ça va bien que ton personnage j'ai
dit d'accord après c'est un peu ça ce
métier c'est ce que les gens projettent
de toi à quel point ça va bloquer ça va
traîner ce que c'était dur après la vida
dette de vérifier ce que je vaux son
adèle voilà sur un plateau sans la
liberté où il ya aucune marque au sol où
la caméra c'est ça devient tableau où tu
peux tourner une heure et demie où c'est
de l'improvisation tout le temps et je
pense que je me suis avouer que j'avais
plus besoin de me prouver des choses à
moi même qu aux autres qu'il y avait des
choses que je n'étais pas capable de
faire et c'était pas grave et d'autres
gens qu'ils aient mieux que moi et que
c'est une question travail je pense
toutes ces années après la palme d'or
que vous allez aussi reporté en tant
qu'actrice qui est complètement inédit
après l'intensité de ce film après les
conditions éprouvantes du tournage dont
on a beaucoup parlé au fond vous en
gardez quelle expérience de la vie
d'adèle pas une grande forme de liberté
toute chose qui ressemble à rien d'autre
en fait y'a vraiment aucune marque au
sol tu commences une scène et il peut te
dire voilà si si à la fin vous devez
vous séparer mais finalement vous avez
envie de vous embrassez vous le faites
donc un grand terrain de jeux si vous
êtes fait peur qu'une caméra soit plus
jamais posés sur vous aussi bien qu'elle
a été posée sur vous parlez latif qui
affiche
non il ya trop de cinéastes que gestion
pour douter de ça mais c'était moi
j'avais peur de me dire est ce que je
suis à la hauteur sans lui sans les
conditions dans lesquelles it mais c'est
pour ça qu'aujourd'hui jeudi que les
castings ça me rassure parce que je sais
que je suis prise pour les bonnes
raisons que c'est une vraie rencontre
avec le personnage que je vais pouvoir
l'honorer rendre justice à cette
histoire et c'est quelque chose qui est
avec désapprendre pas d'elle pour
réapprendre
c'est une bonne question en fait je me
suis rendu compte que c'était vraiment
un travail que des fois j'allais dans
une marque donnée c'est une forme de
conformisme que je connaissais pas du
tout où je me suis dit wind farm ya des
choses qui sont calculées il va falloir
respecter le ps et après je me suis vite
adapté en fonction des réalisations en
fait c'est la question que j'allais vous
poser à quel moment pour vous ça devient
un métier quoi bizarrement je pense
quand j'ai mon fils parce que je me suis
dit c'est mon métier c'est mes choix
c'est une raison pour laquelle je vais
m'absenter c'est face est devenu concret
nous dira s'il faut que ce soit une
sécurité en même temps ça reste par
métier d'incertitude et si on remonte
plus tôt quand est-ce que vous avez su
vous vouliez faire ce métier je suis
petit je fais des cours d'un pro dans le
xviiie et puis un jour il ya une
directrice de castillon qui vient et je
réussis un casting pour faire un court
métrage c'est du bénévolat c'est une
semaine et je me rappel appelé mon père
et dire mais il ya des gens qui sont
payés pour faire ça vous sont payés
genre en plus de prendre tout ce plaisir
là on leur envoie de l'argent j'ai dit
mais c'est incroyable et maintenant pour
vous qu'est ce qui fait une grande
actrice ou même un grand acteur
à quoi ça tient parfois ça tient un
grand rôle
parfois ça tient une rencontre avec un
metteur en scène je sais pas peut-être
que c'est nul mais une fois de plus
j'irai de la sincérité vous a par
exemple découvert dans un registre
comique quand vous connaissez pas
forcément chez quentin dupieux dans la
flamme avec jonathan cohen quelle
jubilation ou est-ce que ça a été ça
d'aller chercher ça ça me faisait peur
par exemple que ce soit pour jonathan
cohen que ce soit pour quentin dupieux
je me dis waouh mais qu'est-ce qui me
dit que ça va marcher entre chaque film
c'est un pari tu dis ça se trouve ça va
s'effondrer je vais pas dû tout assumer
ce rôle qu'on donne je suis pas fait
pour celui là ça m'a fait peur et en
même temps le rire j'ai toujours trouvé
ça meubles et alain de plusieurs noms
c'est dur parce que la première priest à
toute l'équipe technique qui rigole mais
au bout de la quatrième des jours un
bail et tué la réalité des faits et en
même temps je pense qu'en tout cas moi
les comédies qui me font rire c'est
quand c'est vraiment un jouet premier
degré une fois de plus que c'est sincère
quoi oui comme le personnage pour le
coup d agnès dans mon des bulles vous
trouviez que c'était celui qui vous
ressemble et le plus fin et lui ça ouais
parce que ça au jour en plus de ce
transit c'est agnès dans la forme bah
y'a rien qui va en soi un problème
d'élocution est présente elle crie elle
a une manière de se déplacer qui est
très imposante mais dans le fond c'est
c'est peut-être la plus lucide sur les
autres et puis je me suis dit c'est
celle qu'on comprend pas ouais j'aurais
pas un comprimé c'est comme ça vous le
vivez vous je me sens pas incomprise au
point où vraiment ça me touche mais des
fois c'est vrai que des interviews aux
médias waouh c'est marrant il a pensé ça
de moi assez drôle des fois j'ai le
sentiment de pas du tout dégagé qui je
suis parce que j'ai une voix j'ai la
voix de mon oncle
mon épaule et que du coup je ne sais pas
je sais pas j'ai besoin d'être l'opposé
de ce que je dégage c'est bizarre merci
à de mercialys